la bataille d'Alger c'était donc le
quatrième volet de la série c'était la
guerre d'Algérie co écrit par Georges
Marc Benhamou et Benjamin Stora et que
nous avons le plaisir de vous proposer
dans cette émission des Badoc un épisode
nous venons de le voir essentiellement
consacré à l'année 1957 année pivot
d'une sale guerre comme on l'a dépeint
aujourd'hui même si jamais à l'époque
elle ne disait officiellement son nom
Benjamin Stora et maintenant avec nous
sur ce plateau bienvenue Benjamin Stora
et on va rappeler que vous êtes
historien évidemment spécialiste de
l'histoire du Maghreb de l'Algérie et
tout particulièrement de cette guerre
d'Algérie c'est donc vous qui êtes le
co-auteur avec Georges Marc benhamoud
cette série c'était la guerre d'Algérie
nous avons le plaisir de proposer en
intégralité tout au long de cette
semaine dans cette émission débat docs
vous êtes l'auteur du rapport sur les
questions mémoriales portant sur la
colonisation et la guerre d'Algérie que
vous avez commandité Emmanuel Macron en
juillet 2020 ce rapport vous l'avez
remis d'ailleurs janvier 2021 six mois
plus tard et vos propositions pour une
réconciliation mémorielle durable entre
les deux pays figurent dans cet ouvrage
France Algérie les passions douloureuses
publiées chez Albin Michel puis au
chapitre de vos paris Sion on citera
aussi la gangrène et l'oubli publié aux
éditions La Découverte je crois que
c'est un ouvrage quel vous tenez
beaucoup il date un peu cet ouvrage mais
vous considérez que c'est le plus bel
ouvrage que vous ayez pu écrire sur la
mémoire justement autour de cette
fameuse guerre d'Algérie tramorquemener
est avec nous également bonjour vous
êtes historien spécialiste de la guerre
d'Algérie et auteur entre autres de la
guerre d'Algérie en direct co-écrit avec
Philippe Labro et publieuse éditions du
Cerf et historia je conseillerais
réellement cet ouvrage plus de 300
photos des témoignages de journalistes
on est vraiment dans l'époque formidable
ouvrage puis je vais en citer un autre
ouvrage c'est vivre en Algérie au 19e et
au 20e siècle disposibles aux éditions
nouveaux mondes c'est tout chaud il
vient de sortir et c'est un ouvrage de
photographie qui est donc à découvrir
aux éditions nouveaux mondes Benjamin
Stora on va préciser qu'on va parler
ensemble de l'ensemble de cette guerre
d'Algérie autrement dit 1954
1962 même si nous venons de voir un
épisode et Dieu sait s'il est important
qui concerne la bataille d'Alger 1957
les premières années de cette guerre
nous les avons vu hier dans les épisodes
2 et 3 de votre série et puis la fin de
cette guerre on la verra demain dans un
autre débat doc et qui porte sur la
période 58 62 pour commencer parce que
là aussi les chiffres ne sont pas
claires et il y a des distansions entre
la France et l'Algérie sur cette
question combien de victimes a fait
cette guerre dans les deux camps
vous savez qu'il y a toujours des baies
terribles autour des victimes de la
guerre d'Algérie du côté des autorités
algériennes de l'État algérien on a
avancé très vite dès 1963 le chiffre de
1 million et demi de martyrs du côté des
historiens
qui ont travaillé depuis de très longues
années sur cette histoire on avance le
chiffre de 3 à 400000 morts du côté
algérien ce qui est comparable en
rapport avec la population par exemple
le nombre de morts français de la
Première Guerre mondiale ce qui colossal
je pense particuliers aux chiffres
avancés par Charles Robert Ageron qui
est un grand historien sur ces sur ces
chiffres là mais il faut aussi signaler
le nombre de victimes de soldats
français près de 30 000 environ soldats
français qui ont été tués pendant cette
guerre il faut citer aussi des victimes
dans naturellement des Européens
d'Algérie de plusieurs milliers et puis
ceux qui ne figurent pas officiellement
pendant très longtemps de cette guerre
d'Algérie c'est des harkis bien sûr car
il y a eu des massacres de harkis après
pendant notamment pendant l'été 62 et
après et là il y a plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de de personnes qui ont été
tuées dans des conditions terribles dans
250 000 arquis on combattu au côté des
forces françaises et on parle tout de
même de
35000 à 70 000 la fourchette est là qui
tue après cette guerre sur les chiffres
vous savez il y a toujours une espèce
d'inflation générale il y a pas 250 000
articles qui ont combattu au côté de
l'armée française environ un peu plus de
100000 ce qui est déjà aussi colossal
merci c'est inconsidérable c'est un
chiffre que j'ai trouvé par exemple oui
oui mais effectivement les chiffres
ensuite de personnes tuées après disons
le cessez-le-feu notamment évidemment
varie en fonction de des sources mais
entre 25000 et 50000 60000 personnes qui
ont été tuées donc vous voyez il y a des
variations alors il y a pas de chiffres
officiels donnés aussi par l'état
français parce que le seul chiffre
officiel dans le fond qui a été donné
qui a été celui de l'État algérien les
Français
communiquer leurs chiffres de mort
essentiellement pour les militaires les
militaires français 27500 exactement qui
ont été communiqués mais sur les
chiffres civils disons des populations
algériennes qui ont été touchées là ce
sont des chiffres qui peuvent
véritablement été communiqués moi la
question que je me pose c'est de savoir
cette se passer qui ne passe pas cette
expression qui revient très fréquemment
lorsqu'on parle de ce conflit est-ce que
c'est précisément cette guerre d'Algérie
qui a duré 8 ans ou c'est le système de
colonisation française qui ne passe pas
l'expression est née à propos de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale au départ un
passé qui ne passe pas c'était le régime
de Vichy en particulier mais c'est ici
aussi un autre passé qui ne passe pas en
effet la guerre d'Algérie ça a été la
guerre d'indépendance en tant que telle
se passer là non ne passe pas parce que
il y a eu cette énorme déchirure pour
reprendre le alors il passe pas auprès
de qui d'être document on l'imagine des
harkis oui bien sûr c'est c'est une
énorme déchir
de tous les côtés c'était terrible
effectivement du côté des Algériens il y
a une énorme saignée on est sur quand on
regarde effectivement aussi en prenant
autour de 30 000 morts pour du côté
français
à minima peut-être 300000 du côté
algérien c'est un rapport de 1 pour 10
donc c'est gigantesque de ce point de
vue là et donc c'est à la fois une
énorme saignée des déchirements
terribles parce que les Pieds-Noirs
partent en 1962 les harkis sont
massacrés enfin en tout cas une partie
d'entre eux les soldats français ils ont
été ils ont mené une guerre une sale
guerre dans laquelle en fait
à laquelle ils étaient absolument pas
préparés c'était des jeunes gens de 20
ans donc tout ça c'est une un passé du
coup qui ne passe pas mais il y a eu
jusqu'à 400 000 soldats français dont
Catherine 90% étaient des soldats du
contingent complètement en permanence en
permanence 400 000 soldats en permanence
c'est-à-dire sur toute la durée de la
guerre en totalité c'est un million
200000 appelés du contingent auquel il
faut rajouter les rappels qui avait déjà
fait leur service militaire auparavant
et qui sont retournés en Algérie
combattre plus effectivement les
militaires de carrière le tout ça fait à
peu près 2 millions de soldats mais
voilà ce passé qui ne passe pas en fait
aussi il faut voir ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été masqué au bout du compte
cette horreur de la fin de de la
colonisation on va dire l'horreur de
l'indépendance de la guerre
d'indépendance en tant que tel masque
aussi cette longue durée en fait de la
colonisation et c'est au bout du compte
c'est aussi cette colonisation qui est
un passé qui ne passe pas les deux sont
véritables et aujourd'hui en fait on est
on est entré dans cette période là par
la guerre d'indépendance mais
aujourd'hui on remonte sur vraiment
toute la durée de la colonisation pour
mieux connaître toute cette guerre enfin
toute cette période là
ce qui est assez incroyable dans les
chiffres effectivement qui sont avancés
par tremorque et meneur c'est qu'au
démarrage lorsque il y a ce qu'on va
appeler plus tard la guerre d'Algérie ce
sont à peine quelques milliers de
soldats qui sont envoyés pour ce qu'on a
appelé des opérations non pas des
opérations spéciales mais les opérations
de maintien de l'ordre donc on envoie
quelques milliers de militaires des
premières appelées et ce qui est assez
incroyable c'est la montée en puissance
du nombre de soldats qui sont envoyés en
Algérie à partir notamment de 1956 et
surtout 1957 pour atteindre ce chiffre
extravagant de 2 millions de jeunes
Français qui ont été en Algérie vous
imaginez ce que signifie 2 millions de
jeunes soldats français en France
toutes les familles combien y a-t-il de
soldats
indépendantistes ah du côté de du côté
des Algériens alors là aussi c'est une
montée en puissance parce que au
démarrage de cette guerre d'indépendance
il y a quelques milliers disons de
personnes notamment concentrées dans les
oreilles si pour ensuite atteindre des
chiffres de 80000 hommes pour ce qu'on
appelle l'armée des frontières notamment
stationnelles extérieur pour les
chiffres des maquets de l'intérieur
c'est très difficile à évaluer bien
entendu là on n'a pas de chiffres
véritablement de personnes qui étaient
dans ces maquilles mais c'est ce qui
explique ce chiffre incroyable c'est ce
qui explique en particulier ce que vous
avez posé comme question à l'instant
c'est-à-dire le passé qui ne passe pas
ce sont des populations colossales qui
sont concernées que ce soit bien sûr les
Européens d'Algérie près d'un million
qui partent en exil en exode etc bien
sûr on a presque presque 2 millions de
jeunes Français
âgés entre 18 et 25 ans pratiquement
tous les hommes nés entre 1932 et 1943
on fait l'Algérie il faut le savoir si
vous croisiez un homme dans la société
française qui est né dans cette période
là il est allé il côtait l'Algérie
l'Algérie pour lui c'est un souvenir
extraordinaire de son adolescence
aujourd'hui en France on a les
descendants des des pieds-noirs on peut
estimer à là aussi à plusieurs centaines
de milliers de personnes
euh on a évidemment les descendants de
harki et des migrer Algérie en France
illiminerait en France parce que le
chiffre des millions a été multiplié par
deux entre 1954 qui est évalué environ à
200 250 000 personnes à 400000 en 1962
c'est-à-dire qu'on a un doublement par
deux de l'immigration algérienne en
France pendant la guerre d'Algérie qui
est aussi colossal dire qu'on a
plusieurs millions de personnes à cela
il faut ajouter une autre un autre
aspect c'est que si la guerre a du mal
entre guillemets à passer c'est parce
que à la différence des autres colonies
l'Algérie c'était la France c'est-à-dire
que il y avait disons cette notion d'une
Algérie française c'est-à-dire d'une
Algérie qui était gérée par le ministère
de l'Intérieur et non pas par le
ministère des Colonies ce qui fait que
en fait la fin la perte l'abandon enfin
qu'importe le terme de l'Algérie
française est vécu comme une sorte de
blessure nationale comme une blessure
narcissique quelque part du nationalisme
français parce que c'est une partie du
territoire français disons qui est
amputé qui disparaît etc
ce qui fait qu'on peut estimer que la
guerre d'Algérie peut être considérée
aussi comme une guerre civile
franco-française et c'est ce qu'on verra
notamment dans les années 58 62 contre
le général de Gaulle avec l'os etc alors
on va on va bien sûr en dire un mot les
rendez-vous manqués on a vu avec vous
Benjamin Story à l'occasion de du
premier épisode de cette série autour de
la colonisation qui a eu un certain
nombre de rendez-vous manqués avant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et avant la fin
de cette seconde guerre mondiale mais là
aussi il y a eu des rendez-vous manqués
la Toussain rouge 1er novembre 1954
c'est là que tout commence c'est
insurrection menée par le FLN c'est un
certain Pierre Mendès France qui est
président du conseil de la Quatrième
République Mendès France a réussi à
signer la paix en Indochine et
d'économiser l'Indochine il prépare
l'indépendance de la Tunisie du Maroc il
se retrouve avec ce problème algérien
sur les bras et ce qu'il y avait pas
moyen d'éviter cette guerre avec Mendès
France et pourquoi ça n'a pas été le cas
à deux reprises d'ailleurs parce qu'il y
a effectivement cette toute première
période avec Mendès France et c'était
beaucoup déjà il y avait beaucoup de
choses à faire et l'Algérie c'était
effectivement différent c'était aussi
l'Algérie c'est la France ou la France
voilà les deux sont vraiment intimement
liés donc c'est vrai que le pour lui le
problème a été était différent en tant
que tel et la deuxième période en fait
aussi c'est au moment du Front
républicain donc en janvier 1956 avec
ses parties de gauche qui qui arrivent
en fait
qui ont la victoire aux élections
législatives en janvier 1956 et juste à
ce moment là en fait on a plusieurs fois
Guy Mollet qui parle de guerre imbécile
et sans issue donc on a une campagne qui
se fait aussi autour de ça on a beaucoup
de jeunes qui vont s'inscrire sur les
listes des électorales et il y a quelque
chose qui semble se jouer autour de ça
le Front républicain remporte les
élections et d'ailleurs ce qui est tout
à fait passionnant c'est que la
population française attend pour plus de
25%
ce moment là pour les chiffres c'est de
loin la personnalité qui la plus
attendue c'est Pierre mendescence et
Pierre Mendès France tout le monde sait
à ce moment-là qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
auparavant donc quelque part on a cette
idée là aussi peut-être de mettre fin en
fait à ce conflit enfin quoi qu'il en
soit son gouvernement tombera à cause de
la guerre d'Algérie il sera ministre
d'État en 56 sous guimolay et quittera
ce gouvernement à cause de la question
algérienne il quitte le gouvernement
notamment avec d'autres comme à la
Savary et puis la crise à l'intérieur de
ces figures notamment avec Michel Rocard
déjà qui est très jeune à cette époque
là parce qu'il y a eu la résonnement de
l'avion il y avait Ahmed Ben Bella alors
ça c'est la deuxième rendez-vous manqué
vous le soulignez vous le présentez
comme tel d'ailleurs dans cette série 56
on détourne cet avion avec les
principaux dirigeants du FLN je vais
très vite donc évidemment Ben Bella
surtout et là vous nous dites finalement
les accords d'Évian on aurait presque pu
les signer dès cette époque et
s'économiser de fait 6 ans de guerre on
peut penser cela bien sûr c'est toujours
facile de réécrire bien sûr après coup
et de dire bon on aurait pu etc mais il
y avait la possibilité une ouverture
comme on dit une fenêtre de tir entre
guillemets sur les négociations
possibles qui avait commencé secrètement
en fait à Belgrade en 195 en septembre
1956 eu des négociations secrètes et
donc la raisonnement de l'avion de
Mohamed Boudiaf aussi Naït Ahmed Ben
Bella etc
va interrompre disons ce processus de
négociation discussions et la France va
plonger encore plus dans la guerre
d'Algérie et en même temps d'ailleurs
que l'opération de Suez c'était
exactement la même époque et donc on va
plonger en tout cas dernière fenêtre de
tir pour reprendre votre expression de
la 4e c'est la dernière grande fenêtre
parce qu'après on est effectivement dans
une logique implacable d'engrenage de
face à face et de guerre totale
notamment dans l'année 1957 alors ce que
dit aussi Benjamin storat puisque vous
avez consigné cette série
ce sont les ultras qui ont provoqué
cette engrenage ultra dans chacun des
deux camps vous êtes d'accord avec ça ah
oui on explique comme ça cet engrenage
notamment la sur la raisonnement de
l'avion du FLN c'est véritablement ça
d'un côté et de l'autre en fait on a des
personnes qui sont plutôt dans la
négociation qui effectivement négocie
secrètement et qui sont plutôt ouverts à
cela du côté algérien notamment Benbella
effectivement donc cette délégation
extérieure du FLN et la raisonnement par
une frange de militaires en fait aussi
dans l'armée française qui qui bloque
complètement en fait toutes les
négociations d'un côté du côté algérien
ça fait le jeu en fin de compte de
l'aile dur du FLN qui lui est vraiment
partisan d'aller jusqu'au bout de
l'indépendance à tout prix la guerre de
la guerre
révolutionnaire exactement et du côté du
côté du gouvernement de la même manière
guimolay d'ailleurs à saura ce mot pas
éventuellement enfin voilà Aurélie ce
mot-là a les cons en parlant de cette un
raisonnement parce que ça met un terme
définitif à toute à toute possibilité de
négociation faut pas oublier que c'est
l'année 56 c'est aussi l'année où Albert
Camus tente une trêve civile
pourrait éviter précisément la poursuite
du bain de sang et que cette trêve
civile où il est rejeté par les
Européens d'Algérie qui sont contre
cette position là cette politique de la
de la trêve civile et aussi par certains
dirigeants du FLN qui veulent poursuivre
la guerre à outrance et donc Camus se
retrouve plus que jamais ils ont isolés
comme l'ensemble disons de ce qu'on va
appeler plus tard le courant libéral
composé en particulier d'un certain
nombre d'intellectuels etc donc Germaine
si on d'ailleurs à l'époque et là on
plonge dans une dynamique effectivement
d'affrontement qui n'est plus du tout
l'heure n'est plus du tout au
négociations aux discussions aux
possibilités de disons de réconciliation
c'est au contraire disons une une guerre
totale dangereuse d'ailleurs et qui va
avoir des répercussions sur la France
puisque là la le fait de plonger dans
cette guerre totale va ouvrir une crise
politique profonde
du point de vue de la Quatrième
République qui va tomber dans cette
guerre d'Algérie dans cette bataille
d'Alger et elle verra bien sûr
l'accession du général de Gaulle au
pouvoir alors l'accession du général de
Gaulle au pouvoir avec après un putsch
un vrai faux putch dis certains le 13
mai 58 du côté de généraux du côté
d'Alger
le 4 juin il est à Alger le général de
Gaulle et c'est le fameux je vous ai
compris alors qui a compris le goal ce
jour-là et savait-il lui-même parce que
la question est posée dans votre série
où il allait emmener cet Algérie
française de Gaulle ouais tout à fait ça
c'est une très grande question insoluble
et quelque part mais il est certain que
il y avait les mots qui je t'ai dit je
vous ai compris chacun s'y retrouver je
pense qu'il avait dans l'idée de
négocier d'aller dans un dans ce qu'on a
appelé aussi une troisième voie
finalement essayer de dégager des
espaces pour essayer de mieux négocier
et transformer les choses mais au bout
du compte il s'est retrouvé face
toujours à un camp d'ultra très dur qui
a empêché toute évolution et voilà au
bout d'un au bout d'un an c'est une
fraction de l'armée et on le verra après
en 61 avec un autre putsch ce fameux
quarteron de généreux en retraite c'est
comme ça qu'il les appellera mais enfin
une fraction de l'armée fait alliance
avec les ultras de l'Algérie française
complètement tout à fait et là le le la
césure la coupure va véritablement se
faire avec le discours sur
l'autodétermination du 16 septembre 1959
puisque là pour la première fois en fait
il laisse la possibilité à
l'autodétermination c'est à dire
véritablement à l'indépendance en fait
dans l’accession à l'indépendance aussi
qui ne désire pas il appelle la
sécession d'ailleurs mais voilà il
laisse cette possibilité là et là du
coup en fait les ultras vont rentrer en
conflit majeur avec avec le général de
Gaulle notamment au cours de la semaine
des barriques avec voilà une une révolte
là civile pour le coup avant tout contre
les
derniers épisodes bien entendu de votre
série on découvrira demain exactement de
Gaulle et l'Algérie française de Gaulle
c'était un nostalgique de l'Empire
français vous savez oui on a on a
l'image à ta base qui était
indénationaliste
bon qui qui avait pesé les premiers
jalons du nationalisme algérien dans
l'entre-deux-guerres en 1944 alors
qu'elle G est la capitale de l'Empire
français de Gaulle refuse de voir faire
un Tabas de Gaulle là peut-être aucune
envie de de lâcher l'Algérie française
vous savez on a aujourd'hui l'image d'un
de Gaulle décolonisateur c'est quelqu'un
mais ce qu'elle est réelle cette image
est assez simplifiée parce qu'en fait le
général de Gaulle comme ça vient d'être
dit à l'instant lorsqu'il arrive au
pouvoir en 1958 n'est pas forcément pour
l'indépendance de l'Algérie il est pour
l'association parce qu'il dit dans son
célèbre discours du 16 septembre 59 dans
le fond il y a 3 solutions il y a la
possibilité de l'intégration mais ça je
n'y crois plus l'intégration complète de
l'Algérie à la France il y a la
possibilité de l'indépendance et de la
séparation radicale là aussi dit je n'y
crois pas ce n'est pas possible alors il
reste la possibilité dite de
l'association un type de solution
fédérale sera un peu le modèle du
Commonwealth en fait inquiétait à la
mode à cette époque là et il va
s'accrocher à cette idée de troisième
voie de commonwell etc mais c'est le
refus algérien des nationalistes
algériens et puis aussi bien sûr la
montée en puissance de l'os à partir de
la semaine des barricades en janvier 60
qui va pousser le général de Gaulle à
accélérer le pas c'est-à-dire à monter
en puissance sur une position qui est
celle d'un retrait rapide de l’algérie
pratiquement notamment à partir de
l'année 61 surtout lorsqu'il y a le
putsch des généraux d'avril 1961 à ce
moment-là on a une cassure à l'intérieur
de l'appareil d'État et pas n'importe
quelle cassure car le putsch des
généraux contrairement à ce que l'on
croit c'est pas simplement 4 généraux à
la retraite etc c'est de plusieurs
centaines voire plusieurs milliers
d'officiers supérieurs de l'armée
française qui entre en dissidence à
l'intérieur de la succession on va
jusque là hein
c'est très sérieux le putsch d'avril 61
c'est très important et on a par
conséquent là la volonté chez du général
de Gaulle d'en finir au plus vite
c'est-à-dire d'accélérer et là les
solutions type association sont
abandonnés donc vous voyez la position
du général de Gaulle à la elle-même
aussi évoluée lorsqu'il arrive au
pouvoir avec le fameux je vous ai
compris etc il n'est pas du tout évident
qu'il soit attendre plus d'un an avant
d'en arriver à l'auto-détermination qui
lui a soufflé le
une forme de sortie de l'auto alors là
détermination en avril 1959 en fait il y
a il y a un sondage de l'Ifop qui montre
qu'il y a 60 plus de 70% de la
population française qui est partisane
de l'indépendance en fait et donc aussi
il est obligé quelque part par parce que
finalement
l'opinion française elle change elle se
modifie il y a beaucoup de plus en plus
dans une forme d'opposition alors quand
il est arrivé au pouvoir les gens ont
suivi de Gaulle ils étaient ils étaient
à la grande figure quand même mais c'est
une guerre qui dure qui dure longtemps
dans laquelle tous les jeunes gens sont
envoyés qui a des conséquences en termes
aussi économiques qui coûte cher à la
société française tous ces éléments là
font que finalement la société suit de
moins en moins et donc il sait très bien
aussi le général de Gaulle c'est que
c'est quelque chose qui est tout
simplement
il gère en tant que tel il gère l'état
il est pas d'ailleurs pas favorable pas
non plus à une armée de conscription ça
coûte extrêmement cher sur sur
cette mobilisation coûte extrêmement
cher à la société il faut mettre un
terme à cette guerre là d'une manière ou
d'une autre et donc c'est un des moyens
mais pas voilà mais on en arrivera aux
accords d'Évian mars 62 dans la douleur
on s'enferme pendant 11 jours
consignes et d'ailleurs côté français de
qu'on en arrive au bout au bout de 11
jours de rester ensemble d'arriver à
quelque chose ces accords d'Évian ils
ont été quand même très décriés à la
fois par Benbella ensuite et Boumédiène
qui ont été les deux principaux
dirigeants qu'on suit pendant des années
et qui ont pris le pouvoir à la tête de
cette Algérie indépendante
j'étais des bons accords c'était
la question centrale pour les accords
d'Évian pour les appréhender c'est la
sortie de guerre sur la question de la
paix ça vient d'être dit à l'instant par
traverse quéménor de Gaulle c'est
parfaitement que l'opinion publique
française veut en finir avec la guerre
et que cette poursuite de guerre risque
de disons favoriser une crise
dans l'état et donc de sa propre
destitution possible et comme c'est un
homme politique extrêmement avisé il
décide là de alter le pas c'est-à-dire
de d'y aller vraiment la grande
négociation sur Évian dans le fond c'est
quoi c'est le Sahara fondamentalement
c'est à dire la nécessité pour la France
de conserver le Sahara en effet nos
essais nucléaires
on y trouve l'hydrocarbures et le gaz et
le pétrole c'est pour le pour de Gaulle
pour le général de Gaulle la question
centrale c'est la préservation du Sahara
il lâchera sur le Sahara il finira par
lâcher à la table des négociations voilà
mais il menace par exemple
au milieu des négociations et il lance
la menace de la partition à un moment
donné il dit nous allons avoir une
petite partie de l’algérie qui restera
aux mains de la France
naturellement les Algériens refusent la
partition ça c'est évident parce qu'il
veut conserver le Sahara parce que c'est
un lieu extrêmement important mais comme
on le sait c'est négociations vont durer
et se terminer assez rapidement et on a
par conséquent les accords d'Évian qui
sont signés 18 19 mars 1962 mais les
accords d'Évian ne signifie pas la fin
de la guerre d'Algérie c'est ça qu'il
faut bien comprendre aussi ce qu'on a
essayé de montrer dans le documentaire
avec
le découvrira dans votre dans le dernier
épisode absolument c'est à dire que la
guerre va continuer elle va prendre des
proportions absolument inouïe de
violence moi personnellement j'étais
enfant à cette époque-là j'aimerais une
douzaine d'années et je me souviens très
bien de cette période terrible entre le
mois de février 62 et juin juillet 62
bah c'était une période de couvre-feu
d'arrestation de confinement en fait de
terreur qui a existé c'est la période la
plus dure en fait une des périodes
facturation au sein de
cette Algérie le jour même de
l'indépendance les massacres de
pieds-noirs à Oran 5 juillet 1962 les
harkis bien entendu on a parlé mais on
en a parlé tout à l'heure ils ont été
respectés ces accords d'Évian malgré
tout difficilement il y a eu une partie
effectivement qui a été respectée
puisque il y a eu des accords qui ont
fait qu'il y a eu une liberté de
circulation par exemple il y a pas un
problème mémorial aujourd'hui encore
autour de du respect ou non
il y a des difficultés évidemment donc
là de ce point de vue là non on sait
jamais conclu il y a donc les accords
d'Évian sont des accords de cesser le
feu par contre il n'y a jamais eu la
paix signée en tant que tel donc ça
c'est une différence aussi de paix un
traité de paix ou un traité d'amitié par
exemple sont des choses qui n'ont jamais
été faites donc on a on est on a laissé
les armes quelque part on les a posés
mais finalement le conflit ne s'est
jamais terminé en tant que avec avec une
dimension aussi qu'il faut ajouter de
par rapport à ce qui venait dit bien sûr
c'est la notion d'amnistie qui va
exister dans les accords d'Évian c'est à
dire que personne ne peut être poursuivi
pour des exactions commises pendant la
guerre d'Algérie c'est très important
cette notion d'amnistie parce que
quelque part l'amnistie va favoriser
l'amnésie en fait c'est à dire que
puisque personne n'a jamais ne sera jugé
poursuivi sur la question de des
exactions commises alors l'amnésie va
s'installer il y aura jamais il y a
jamais eu de grands procès autour de la
question de la guerre d'Algérie des
acteurs de ceux qui sont engagés dans la
bataille d'Alger par exemple etc ça
n'existe pas le celui qui a essayé de
briser disons se blocus mémoriel autour
de cette amnésie c'est Michel Rocard
encore lui encore une fois qui avait
effectivement essayé dans les années 80
de faire poursuivre disons les auteurs
mais ça n'a pas marché puisque François
Mitterrand qui était Président de la
République en 1982 a décidé de
réintégrer
dans leur grade pension et décoration
les généraux puccistes d'avril 1961 donc
vous voyez que au niveau de l'appareil
d'État et bien il y a eu aussi cette
sorte d'amnésie entretenue et il faut
ajouter quand même une amnésie
volontaire ou un consentement quelque
part dans la société française des
années 60-70 de vouloir tourner la page
de vouloir oublier l'Algérie mais
c'était pas possible d'oublier l'Algérie
il y a eu trop de 100 versets trop de
traumatismes trop de problèmes et cet
Algérie progressivement et revenu dans
le débat public c'était la fin de
l'omertante en tout cas on va tout de
même rappeler qu'il faut attendre 1999
et Jacques Chirac pour enfin on mette le
mot guerre sur ce qui s'est passé en
Algérie entre 1954 et 1962 vous avez
participé à la commission Stora oui vous
adhérez donc j'imagine à l'essentiel des
propositions qui a fait de Benjamin
Stora il y a eu du chemin de parcouru
notamment à leur François Hollande
puis bien sûr Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
pourriez dire alors qu'Emmanuel Macron
était celui qui qui a fait le plus pour
essayer de renouer des liens entre ces
deux pays alors on pense bien sûr à la
reconnaissance par la France de
l'assassinat de Maurice Audin d'une part
et Dali bubendell qui était un avocat il
vous préconisiez d'ailleurs cette
cette reconnaissance par l'État français
est-ce que vous pourriez vous estimez
aujourd'hui Macron Emmanuel Macron a
réellement fait un grand pas pour une
réconciliation entre les deux les deux
pays un pas en tout cas bien supérieur à
ceux de ses prédécesseurs oui déjà
Emmanuel Macron voilà et beaucoup plus
jeune on n'a pas participé aux
événements n'est pas directement lié du
coup il y a une véritable montée en
puissance quelque part il y a une
volonté je pense aussi chez Emmanuel
Macron qui a travaillé avec le
philosophe Paul Ricard dans sa jeunesse
Qui est Paul Ricard donc ce philosophe
là avait écrit l'histoire la mémoire
l'oubli absolument donc un vrai
philosophe spécialiste justement des
questions mémoriales aussi et Emmanuel
Macron c'est un s'empare aussi de ce de
ce sujet là justement qu'il sait
gangrener pour reprendre le terme de
votre livre véritablement la société
française la société française elle est
elle est pétrie quelque part de cette
mémoire de la guerre d'Algérie et c'est
reprendre ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
un passé qui ne passe pas donc il y a
quelque chose il y a vraiment quelque
chose à faire autour de cela et il y a
des choses effectivement qui ont été
réalisées vous le disiez tout à l'heure
depuis la reconnaissance de la guerre
d'Algérie en tant que telle François
Hollande aussi par exemple sur le 17
octobre 61 mais là il y a vraiment on
change de dimension aussi avec le
rapport storage justement un rapport qui
commanditait par le Président de la
République ce n'est pas rien ça montre
une volonté aussi de d'agir
véritablement sur sur les causes un
petit peu de de les causes de les
raisons pour lesquelles cela travaille
c'était française et au-delà évidemment
de simplement la France la société
française évidemment des relations entre
les deux pays parce que toutes les
relations entre les deux pays sont
pétries aussi de cette mémoire qui même
chose gangrène les relations bilatérales
un grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette émission à la suite du
quatrième épisode de votre série vous
avez coécrit bien sûr et que Georges
Marc Benhamou merci d'avoir été avec
nous vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag
des Badoc bien sûr sur Twitter le
dernier épisode de votre série ça sera
demain soir dans cette émission d'evadoc
elle concernera donc cette période 58 62
et évidemment l'indépendance de
l'Algérie le 5 juillet 1962 et la fin de
cette salle guerre puisque c'est comme
ça que vous l'avez aussi nommé dans
votre série à très bientôt à tous pour
un nouveau débat doc ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat
[Musique]